[Music]
uipath reboot work
[Music]
america's rollout of the coronavirus
vaccine is way behind schedule
some who have qualified for the vaccine
have been left waiting hours for their
first shot and yet millions more doses
have yet to be distributed at all
manuel bejorquez is at jackson memorial
hospital in miami-dade county florida
manny good morning to you
why is this happening well good morning
part of the problem is many states and
counties are just now
setting up the systems they need to roll
out the vaccine here at jackson memorial
in miami
the hospital launched its online
registration portal for people 65
and over yesterday within two hours
all 12 thousand slots had been filled
and that high demand is playing out
all over the country hundreds of senior
citizens across florida have camped out
overnight all week
desperate to get a covet 19 vaccine i
didn't enjoy sleeping in the car
to get the shot but it was well worth it
florida has only administered about 23
percent of its more than one million
doses
some seniors have gotten so desperate
they reached out to a reporter for the
tallahassee democrat for help signing up
she took to facebook asking for patience
writing i have 75 messages to return in
my
voicemail box is full but i will do my
best to get back to you
over to war and then they sent out the
supplies
to every small town and said now figure
out how you're going to fight the war
barry witt says he called lee county's
reservation hotline
95 times to try to make an appointment
he got through once only to be
disconnected
it started asking some questions but it
was a robo
call after its registration phone line
jammed brevard county turned to
eventbrite
a website best known for selling concert
tickets
i don't think that anyone was prepared
for the phone lines to just
seize up like they did but even that
plan is causing trouble
at least two counties warned seniors
about fake eventbrite accounts
charging people to register in arizona
the national guard
is training retired medical
professionals and current medical
students to give the vaccine
in order to speed up the effort and in
new york governor andrew cuomo says
thousands of sites including new york
city's largest convention center
will eventually be used to distribute
the vaccine
again we need the supply to do that but
we are already setting those up
despite the slow vaccine rollout the
nation's top
infectious disease experts struck a
positive tone on tuesday dr anthony
fauci said he believes
things are starting to pick up and that
the u.s could get to the point where it
is vaccinating
at least